lesina do you still want asuelo and  kalani to divorce  i love my son and i apologize for what  i'm saying i don't want as well  to lose his sons and his wife  and their beautiful family with granny's  mom and dad  and lisa everyone is so kind and  very very good to me  you so kind to my poor son and  he came here visit me  and he talked to me something happened  with him  and kalani and he told me  everything and i was so  mad so i told him everything  how to live with his wife  taking care of the kids stop going to  the volleyball  stop going to the dancing stop going  everywhere  please stay home take care of your wife  and the kids because now you're here in  america you're not a boy you are a big  man  now so you better focus for your family  especially your kids  kalani will you accept uh lucina's  apology  yeah i always accept his mom's apologies  i i'm  i'm fine to have a relationship with her  let's leave it at them okay  [Music]  you